hi kung fu welcome back
after months of lockdown dentists are
back in business
but opening was just half the battle
is that okay the last month has shown
how different things will have to be
so how is it being back at the dentist
it's uh it's it's great
it's a bit of a return to normality
but real normality is still a long way
off there's a backlog of work and
dentists are warning of a looming crisis
this is a new norm things have gone
unchecked and people are going to come
out worse off
and that's a concern for us dentists to
deal with the deluge patients have a
three-month hiatus and they
haven't had their regular checkups and
their hygiene appointments so
i'm doing my best to get as many
patients back in but yeah there's always
that fear
that we could go back again to the
second wave
thank you we all know going to places
like the dentist is a bit different now
thank you you have to wear a mask
there's temperature checks hand
sanitizer
it's all about keeping the patients and
staff here safe
but some of those restrictions can cause
real challenges
after any treatment involving drilling
rooms have to be cleaned and left
empty for an hour many dentists simply
don't have the means to reopen
my real worry is that if the government
doesn't support the profession
over a long period of time
the access to nhs care will worsen
uh as many of my private colleagues
close and the only place for those
patients to turn
is the existing nhs provision which
pre-covered was very very difficult for
patients
to get into an nhs dentist the longer
the profession is not supported
the worse that will get and that really
worries me pleasure seeing you
the governments say they've taken action
to support dentists
and robust arrangements are in place to
ensure patients can access
treatment thanks cheers bye-bye
but as dentists get through the backlog
this is a problem not just about
practicalities
but our health too ali fortescue sky
news